[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires dans l'actualité
cette semaine évidemment toujours et
encore la crise sanitaire
une semaine marquée par une
recrudescence des cas de curry 19 dans
toute la france et des mesures
sanitaires renforcés dans de nombreuses
villes comme bordeaux lille paris et
bien sûr en ile de france
à cette occasion de nouveau gouvernement
a annoncé la création de points pour se
faire tester avec des résultats sous 24
heures
les équipes de tv 78 vous allez le voir
sont allés se rendre compte à trappes
dans les yvelines
si cela marche et bien regardez ce
reportage quelques minutes d'attentes
avant d'être testé depuis lundi 21
septembre trappe accueille un centre de
dépistage et de diagnostic qu'ovide
d'ici trois semaines le laboratoire
espère réaliser 500 tests quotidiens
l'espoir qu'on a tous s'est essayé à la
volonté de la rs qui est vraiment de
faciliter l'accès aux prélèvements dans
des délais courts pour les personnes
prioritaires les personnes prioritaires
c'est vraiment celle qui seraient
susceptibles de propager l'épidémie
parce qu elles parce qu'elles sont
positives et parce qu'elles sont en
contact avec des gens cinq opérateurs de
saisie et trois infirmières permettent
un rendu de résultats sous 24 heures
le centre est ouvert six jours sur sept
il est accessible sur prescription
médicale ou pour les personnes
contactées par la rs ou la sécurité
sociale on a détecté ya qui est des
signes de covin mais en fait c'est une
rhinopharyngite comme tous les ans donc
par précaution comme il est asthmatique
on comprend ça faire le test du
cognassier le départ maintenant c'est
mon année résultat s'est rapidement donc
moi ça m'intéresse pour retourner en
cour le puits de possibles j'ai des
symptômes moi j'ai eu des fièvres
voilà donc du coup j'ai par mesure de
précaution je suis venu faire le test
un deuxième centre est installé à
mantes-la-jolie d'ici quinze jours ce
sont vingt sites qui testeront sur toute
la région francilienne pour la semaine
du 7 au 13 septembre un peu plus de 6%
des personnes testées ont été déclarées
positives
le département est classé en zone active
de circulation du virus
nous partons cette fois en normandie
dans le grand jt des territoires pour
une initiative solidaire
330 clavier d'ordinateur antimicrobiens
ont été financés et vont être offerts à
des établissements de santé de l'eure et
de seine-maritime
comme l'expliquent ce reportage de lcn
la chaîne normande sur place aider les
soignants dans l'application des mesures
sanitaires contre la copie de 19
c'est le défi que se sont lancés et riou
glass et crédit agricole normandie seine
en offrant 330 clavier antibactérien
antivirus aux établissements publics de
santé de l'eure et de la seine-maritime
aujourd'hui on est venu célébrer d'abord
une entreprise emblématique du
territoire qu'est riou glass une famille
d'entrepreneurs qui la famille riou
représentée par pierre rioux bien sûr et
puis on est on est venu célébrer le
modèle du crédit agricole donc une bonne
coopérative mutualiste de plein exercice
avec nos caisses locales nos
administrateurs nos collaborateurs on a
décidé de se mobiliser fortement tout
azimut à la fois pour soutenir nos aînés
soutenir des clients plus fragiles comme
des familles des femmes battues des
clients très grande situation de
fragilité
pendant toute cette période et c'est un
million d'euros d'actions de caisse
locale de solidarité dont celle que nous
faisons avec l'entreprise pierre rioux
et surtout on a mobilisé toutes nos
caisses locales
soixante-et-une sur 71 ont été mobilisés
330 clavier qui ont été achetés par les
caisses locales et qui vont être
distribués à une trentaine
d'établissements sur le territoire la
fois des établissements médicaux et
aussi des établissements pour personnes
âgées des trades
l'entreprise riou glass a été créée il
ya une quarantaine d'années par par mes
parents on est
à la base des transformateurs de
produits verriers donc essentiellement à
destination du bâtiment
nos clients sont des menuisiers des
façadiers des agenceurs d'intérieur et
depuis 2012 nous avons remonté la
filière du verre et on est devenus
producteurs de verre plat aujourd'hui
crée le clavier c'est aussi une volonté
de se diversifier de pas rester
uniquement sur notre notre marché
historique
donc on a effectivement le clavier on a
les radiateurs en verre on a aussi la
gamme dit jia glace qui a été sorti
pendant la période de qu'ovide à partir
du moment où on peut électrifier le vert
le transformer on peut on peut faire la
multitude de produits on en a encore
plein plein dans les dents le
laboratoire le partenariat crédit
agricole est historique c'est la banque
qui a accompagné mes parents à leurs
débuts et qui nous a accompagnés pendant
pendant toutes les années des années
plus facile les années plus difficiles
de la vie des entreprises donc
aujourd'hui
belle preuve d'amour si on peut le dire
ainsi va la vie que de sceller ce
partenariat sur un beau projet comme
celui-ci
voilà parlons à présent de l'impact
économique de cette crise sanitaire
c'est lors du bilan un peu partout pour
la saison touristique en france malgré
les craintes certaines régions ont pu
tout de même affiché de bons résultats
c'est le cas en occitanie où le verdict
est tombé cette semaine le détail avec
ce reportage de nos confrères de vie
occitanie sur place des terrasses
bondées des ruelles qui déborde de
vacanciers
un mois de septembre rêvée pour le
tourisme à col du tour dans les pyrénées
orientales la carte postale fait du bien
aux professionnels dans un contexte
sanitaire très incertain début septembre
et la continuation de juillet d'août
donc il ya du monde et ça va continuer
les touristes sont au rendez vous et ça
se ressent hôteliers restaurateurs ont
enregistré une hausse de fréquentation
de 7 % par rapport à l'an dernier à la
même période
certains établissements affichent même
complet tous les week-ends jusqu'à la
fin du mois pour nous c'est un mois de
septembre qui se présente très bien avec
des clientèles françaises bien
évidemment essentiellement jeune on a
beaucoup travaillé sur la communication
à destination cette clientèle puisqu'on
s'attendait à une perte du côté des
clientèles troisième âge qui n'a pas eu
lieu puisque en fait ils sont bien
présents sur notre destination
si les touristes ont continué à
plébisciter le littoral de notre région
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas hésité à prendre l'air
dans l'arrière-pays
car la mise au vert c'est l'une des
tendances qui s'est dégagée durant ces
grandes vacances post confinement y ait
foule et le bruit ça on n'a pas envie
d'être regroupés avec beaucoup de gens
surtout enfermé va pas se mentir avec ce
qui s'est passé ici à sommières dans le
gard dans ce domaine qui propose des
sports de pleine nature l'activité au
mois d'août à tourner à plein régime
on a réellement
une progression en tout cas là sur la
deuxième partie du mois d'août
nous on sent quand même qu'ils sont bien
contents de se retrouver dans les arbres
dans la nature de se reconnecter avec le
avec le milieu naturel savons qu on sent
qu'à ce besoin là aussi sur la période
estivale les vacances à la campagne ont
représenté 30% des séjours de la
clientèle française
voilà et puis je signale cette semaine
l'édition locale du magazine le point
consacré à strasbourg comme vous le
voyez sur cet écran est cette jeune
fille en vélo symbole du déplacement
dans strasbourg
aujourd'hui de nombreux thèmes retenus
par jérôme cordelier et ses équipes sont
développées dans l'édition locale du
point économique industrielle ce casse
tête
aussi pour ce marché de noël très connue
des téléspectateurs de tv5monde à
l'international évidemment un marché qui
devra se tenir à l'heure du coc vide 19
et puis également le nom tourisme sur la
route des vins d'alsace
vous savez ce sont des vins apprécié
dans le monde entier qui sont donc dans
cette édition locale du point cette
semaine consacrée à strasbourg voilà
maintenant un débat qui passionne
en france la mise en place de la 5g sur
l'ensemble du territoire fait beaucoup
parler et vous allez voir dans ce
reportage réalisé en ille et vilaine
le maire de rennes pourtant très
favorable à l'installation de la 5g a
demandé un audit sur celle ci ce qui a
eu pour conséquence de créer une levée
de boucliers des principaux chefs
d'entreprise du département
toutes les explications avec nos
confrères de thé vert à m sur place
première question qu'est ce que recouvre
en fait le travail de la commission de
suivi sur les effets d'implantation de
la 5g mise en place par li lu rennais
pierre janin à la demande de la mère
nathalie appéré
avant de partir sur un déploiement
massif qui pourrait se faire à l'aveuglé
et bien se dire on fait une pause on
regarde pas longtemps ça va être court
on regarde avec tous les partenaires
possibles tous les gens intéressés
qu'ils soient du milieu économique du
milieu associatif
ou de la santé par exemple de regarder
avec eux quels sont les impacts les
avantages les inconvénients de cette
nouvelle technologie qu'est la 5g cette
décision a c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire agacer les centaines
d'entreprises et de laboratoires
reinette de technologie qui totalisent
plus de 30000 emplois dans
l'agglomération exemple avec digitaleo
et ses 55 salariés
le seul truc c'est que prenant pas trop
de temps dans les études qu'ils sont
déjà faites au niveau national et
international et je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance à tous ceux qui
travaillent autour la 5g pour faire ça
avec responsabilité et justement pour
pas pris trop de temps parce que
j'aurais peur qu'on leur haine ensuite
qui est aujourd'hui encore une fois un
perso de télécoms de l'innovation autour
des réseaux se retrouve en queue de
peloton
même son de cloche dans l'un des hauts
lieux du numérique rennais l'institut de
recherche technologique become c'est
tout simplement aujourd'hui le premier
opérateur de tests 5g en france
autant dire qu'ici au respire déjà la 5g
les enjeux sont dans tous nos actes
ready la ville intelligente de demain la
mobilité et la voiture connectée
l'industrie du futur et la capacité dans
nos usines agroalimentaires d'être plus
efficace plus économes
l'énergie est la capacité à gérer et à
mélanger des énergies issues des
énergies renouvelables mais comme des
énergies plus traditionnelle tous ces
éléments là la santé connecté on en part
alors beaucoup parlent de l'opération à
distance plus que de l'opération à
distance la capacité à accéder l'expert
dans un moment de stress majeur pour
aider la personne qui est en situation
d'opérer d'intervenir sur un feu dans
une situation de crise tous à la 5g
aujourd'hui offrira des solutions que la
4g aura énormément de mal à supporter
donc c'est pour ça qu'elle c'est pour ça
que la 5g se fera de façon certaine on
parle pas de deux
d'arrêter tout développement a jamais de
cet ovale étudier on va l'étudier
calmement on est on est là pour
réfléchir ensemble à une technologie je
dirais intelligentes
comment utiliser une technologie en 2020
en 2030 en 2040 et comment être être
fier de ce qu'on aura fait est que nos
enfants les enfants de nos enfants
diront oui vous avez raison de vous
poser six mois rendez compte que vous
posez six mois pour étudier l'impact
d'une technologie reste un sujet d'une
grande complexité
par exemple les scientifiques assurent
que les performances maximales promise
par les réseaux 5g ne seront pas une
réalité avant cinq ou dix ans et à ce
moment là ce sera le temps de la 6 g qui
semble-t-il est déjà dans les cartons
nous partons dans la loire à présent
dans le camp j'y tenais territoire pour
parler de commerce de proximité le
centre commercial style a ouvert ses
portes à saint-etienne dans une ville où
le commerce de centre ville souffre
énormément l'ouverture de ce géant
d'acier de 70 mille mètres carrés à
l'entrée de la ville inquiète énormément
certains commerçants même préféré
s'installer à style plutôt qu'en centre
ville
tous les détails avec nos confrères de
tn cette télé loire 7 sur place dernier
coup de chiffon sur les vitres à
quelques heures de l'ouverture tout doit
être parfait pour accueillir les
premiers visiteurs
on va présenter le mieux possible pour
les nouveaux arrivants car après cinq
ans de travaux les boutiques sont
impatientes d'ouvrir leurs portes dans
ses allées tous veulent profiter de la
zone de chalandise estimé à 600 mille
personnes c'est une entrée de ville qui
est première quand vous arrivez de lyon
quand vous passez sur l' axe clermont
ferrand lyon et donc il y avait
également cette deuxième objectif de
répondre à l'évasion commerciale de plus
de 500 millions d'euros deux
consommateurs de la zone de chalandise
de saint-etienne environ six cent mille
habitants
le pâtissier ligériens franck deville
n'a donc pas hésité à investir 200 mille
euros dans son magasin ou le macaron est
roi un investissement qu'il n'aurait pas
fait en centre ville on a besoin de deux
flux pour pouvoir vendre tous ces
produits là quand on vole pas ni moyen
de bain d'un macaron qui va vous signé
un euro di sano revin
comprendrait que en centre ville si on
voit passer que 100 clients la journée
ça risque d'être compliqué
économiquement parlant
un peu plus loin cette maroquinerie qui
a quitté le centre ville pour
s'installer au style espère bien toucher
une clientèle extérieure
bon en fait la zone de chalandise
s'adresse pas du tout la clientèle
forcément stéphanoise s'adresse aussi à
ceux qui habitent autour et qui
cherchent du service et qu'ils le
trouveront ici au style abrite deux
grosses locomotives sens et drainer du
monde et il en faudra pour amortir les
200 millions d'euros investis au départ
où je pense que véritablement tant
qu'investisseur privé on un v6 et de ah
ben si c'est une entreprise familiale et
on investit notre propre argent dans ce
genre d'opération eh ben on croit dans
ce territoire on va s'investir sur
plusieurs des saignées au travers de ce
projet est donc on pense que
saint-etienne est en train de rebondir
et qu'elle va connaître un développement
économique extrêmement important est que
très modestement 6 il peut participer à
ça ce rebond économique et ben on en
serait très heureux et très fier le pari
est lancé à l'ouverture cet après-midi
ils étaient déjà plusieurs centaines
regardez maintenant ces images du
ministre de la justice du garde des
sceaux eric dupond moretti qui s'est
rendu dans le département de l'aube
comme vous pouvez le voir tourner par
nos confrères de canal 32 eric dupond
moretti a assisté à la cérémonie du
souvenir à la prison de clairvaux
le ministre a souhaité dans son discours
revaloriser le métier de surveillant
je vous rappelle que ce centre
pénitentiaire historique doit fermer ses
portes en 2023 dans l'actualité
maintenant direction le grand test
direction epinal et son important
régiment de militaires les équipes de
via vosges ont pu assister au dernier
entraînement du 1er régiment de
tirailleurs qui s'apprêtent à partir en
opérations au mali
vous le savez dans un contexte très
périlleux pour nos soldats sur place
voici le reportage regarder
c'est le genre de scénario qui pourrait
bien se reproduire dans quelques
semaines au mali
sur le terrain militaire de razimet les
soldats du 1er régiment de tirailleurs
d'epinal et leurs renforts sont en
pleine séance d'entraînement en vue de
leur prochain départ en opérations
extérieures ici avec la simulation d'un
nation données sur un bivouac de
terroristes le tout dans des conditions
qui se veulent taux plus proche de la
réalité
là il croit que les du coup le personnel
de la station il a été évacué avec le
blessé
ils ont fait la zone ce qui est clair
pour nous ce qui va nous permettre
éléments génique d'aller fouiller la
zone pour vérifier ce qui revient sur
place rien de dangereux
une fois qu'on aura terminé sa les
comptes-rendus passeront une fois que ce
sera terminé on pourra sortir de la zone
prévue mi-octobre le prochain départ en
mission vers à partir près de la moitié
des soldats du premier tir soit environ
600 militaires dans le cadre de
l'opération barkan au nord du mali c'est
une mission qui évidemment est multiple
et varié avec de longues opérations dans
le désert et qui vise à occuper le
terrain à identifier les terroristes à
les déceler et à les neutraliser
si nous les si nous les trouverons un
terrain très dangereux rappelons que le
bilan actuel s'élève à 45 soldat
français mort au combat au mali depuis
s'il est impossible de reproduire à 100%
les conditions dans lesquelles seront
baigner les militaires notamment la
chaleur qui s'élève à près de 50 degrés
en plein désert l'objectif de ces
entraînements et de se préparer au mieux
on s'entraîne depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant on est passé dans différents
centres d'entraînement avec une grosse
phase de préparation pour le tir on a pu
tirer avec l'ensemble du spectre
l'armement de la lema compagnie avec une
phase d'entraînement à canjuers au
détachement résistance opérationnelle ou
là vraiment on a été on s'est entraîné
aux procédures propres au théâtre malien
aux quatre delà de la bande sahélo
saharienne
dans le cas de l'opération barkan
renforcé par la présence des compagnies
d'autres régiments l'opération démarrera
d'ici quelques semaines
les soldats du premier tir rejoindront
alors les 5000 militaires français déjà
déployés sur la base malienne pour une
mission de plusieurs mois mais avant
leur départ une partie d'entre eux
feront
au revoir à la ville lors d'une
cérémonie officielle le 16 octobre
prochain
voilà dans l'actualité maintenant un
patrimoine local qui risque de
disparaître
direction les hôtes france direction
blériot plage près de calais où les 233
chalet posé sur la plage sont en sursis
leur construction qui date des années 50
ne sont plus du tout conforme à la loi
sur le littoral
une démolition collective est envisagé
d'ailleurs par la municipalité
caroline fichten pour la chaîne wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord s'est rendu
sur place
regardez mon père vincent philippe ibom
a passé toutes ses vacances d'enfant
dans ce chalet à quelques kilomètres de
chez lui
la plage de blériot c'est un lieu chargé
de souvenirs heureux on est ici pendant
deux mois et demi c'est à dire que quand
l'école est finie le foreman de la fin
des colons arrivés ici
ma mère faisait des voyages comme si on
allait faire 500 km et on revenait à la
maison deux mois et demi plus tard la
veille de la rentrée des classes c'est
que dès lors au jour d'hui c'est loïc
l'est celle qui est propriétaire du
chalet il l'a rachetée il ya plusieurs
années quand c'était encore possible
mais ces chalets sont menacés la loi
littoral impose qu'ils soient de taille
inférieure et surtout démontable donc un
démontage donc deux cent trente chalets
à démonter 230 chaleur à remonter mais
ça va prendre huit mois quoi ça va
prendre six mois
donc le problème c'est que techniquement
c'est passé pas faisable
l'association qui assure aussi que
seychelles et joue un rôle dans le
captage et le maintien du sable sur la
plage voudraient tenter de les faire
classer pour les protéger de façon
pérenne
lord on l'a déjà fait des tentatives de
classement at-il de patrimoine
en france mais alors le problème c'est
que on va confronter plusieurs
ministères les uns aux autres et c'est
pas possible on peut parier mon papa ça
peut pas aboutir surtout qu'on est pas
propriétaire des terrains par contre on
est en train de décès de deux de traves
de faire des démarches au niveau 2 au
niveau de l'europe
et puis de peut-être travailler sur sur
l'idée d'un patrimoine immatériel un
patrimoine immatériel car au delà des
cabanes en bois en elle-même ses chalets
sont autant de traces visibles de
l'histoire et des histoires des
habitants c'est cela aussi que
l'association souhaite protéger
c'est une course extraordinaire une
course automobile
évidemment dont le nom résonne à travers
le monde les 24 heures du mans reporté
en raison de la pandémie la 88ème
édition a pu se tenir le week-end
dernier une édition extraordinaire
inédite sans public pour la première
fois de son histoire la sarthe et toute
la région tout de même vibré comme le
montre ce reportage de nos confrères sur
place de lmtv sorte
regardez je suis avec magali pêcheurs
commissaires de course
merci d'être avec nous comment on
devient commissaire de course magali
alors je pense combien commissaires de
piste avant tout par passion parce que
c'est quelque chose de bénévoles déjà un
premier temps et aussi parce qu'il faut
aimer tout simplement le sport auto
huile dans sa globalité c'est des
grosses journées mais par contre on a
accès à des moments privilégiés
voilà auprès de voitures d'exception moi
je suis vraiment une passionnée même
dans la vie perso parce que je travaille
dans un garage
donc j'en ai fait j'en ai fait ma
profession du coup fut dans l'auto donc
perso dans le pro et et le mans à 30 ans
c'est la première fois que tu viens
mettait déjà rendu au mans mais pour une
course de karting international mais pas
pour les 24 heures effectivement j'en
avais jamais eu l'occasion
parce que c'est quand même à 700 km de
chez moi donc c'est pas la porte à côté
dernière question c'est une vraie
communauté là vous êtes sur un tout
petit moment de pause où on voit il ya
une cohésion dans l'équipe
effectivement moi je suis arrivé
mercredi soir donc d'alsace est un peu
sur la nuit tombante il fallait monter
la tente donc j'ai eu l'aide de tous les
gens présents sur le contenant donc
c'est des gens que je n'ai jamais
rencontré et que j'ai eue pour la
plupart n'aime pas au téléphone
donc il ya vraiment eu un gros mouvement
dont traite une vraie famille on prend
lire pas tous ensemble sous le barnum
on discute on échange on papote c'est
que c'est que du bonheur merci mille
fois pour ton engagement en tout cas
magali cap sur la corse maintenant dans
ce grand jt des territoires avec une
belle leçon de vie vous allez le voir se
surpasser et démontrer que la vie
justement ne s'arrête pas avec le
handicap
et bien c'est un leitmotiv cher à
thierry corbalan alias le dauphin corse
qui l'a conduit à se lancer cette ultime
et nouveau défi traverser la
méditerranée à la nage s'il n'en est pas
à son premier challenge sa volonté reste
la même venir en aide aux personnes
atteintes de maladies ou de handicaps
c'est un magnifique reportage signé des
équipes de nos confrères via télévisé
sur place regardez vous tenter un ultime
défi pourquoi pour clore onze années de
défi de
de nage onze années où j'ai essayé de
montrer que les gens jettent est
possible malgré un accident et j'ai
décidé que ce serait le dernier pour ce
dernier j'ai voulu retourner sur les
lieux où j'ai eu l'accident pour finir
où tout a commencé
vous voulez vous prouver une nouvelle
fois s'est montré que malgré un handicap
on peut faire des choses donc j'essaie
de faire des défis justement pour qu'on
en parle
puis ça permet de parler de mon
association le dauphin corse qui aide
les personnes malades et handicapées à
se reconstruire
essayer d'attirer les personnes qui ont
encore qu'un souci dans la vie de leur
montrer qu'on peut rebondir sur le veut
si on est motivés déterminés rejoindre
monde eu lieu la napoule pour vous ce
n'est pas hasard il se trouve que je
vais arriver le jour de l'anniversaire
de l'ami qui m'a sauvé la vie
daniel est donc je pense que c'est pas
du hasard vous allez nager
combien de temps par jour départ je
passe sur dix 10 à 12 heures par jour et
puis après on verra si jeune âge plus ou
moins qu'elle a été la praye directeur
ballon suite à votre accident je me suis
remise de suite aux sports non jeu au
départ j'ai commencé à faire de la
course à pied j'ai fait de la course à
pied pendant 20 ans je me suis mis à
nager puis c'est là que j'ai fait mon
premier défi en 2009 grâce à frank bruno
qui a amputé tibia qui a une association
et kim avait organisé un défi pour son
association
et c'est à partir de là que j'ai vu que
en argent je pouvais aider les autres
alors j'ai continué et tous les ans
j'essaie de faire des défis j'ai créé ma
propre association et je m'aperçois
qu'en faisant des défis mais je peux
aider les autres personnes à se
reconstruire et des personnes qui ne
croient pas en elle et c'est surtout
pour ça que je le fais parce que ça
c'est ce qui me motive
et puis maintenant c'est du bonheur
j'aimerais que ma vie actuelle et est
mieux que celle que j'ai connue avant
nous partons à présent ensuite et en
bretagne découvrir des vins breton ils
connaissent un franc succès chardonnay
pinot noir ou encore gamma ray suisse
ces cépages sont ceux récoltés en ce
moment par les vignerons du coteau du
braden à quimper
l'une des raisons de cette réussite
c'est le changement climatique vous
allez le voir toutes les explications de
nos confrères de tv ou été mis sur les
chaînes de tnt
de bretagne regarder une bonne saveur
sucrée une déjà une légère pointe
d'acidité pas de saveur normal nora un
vin de qualité normalement avec
quasiment un mois d'avancé le cépage
chardonnay du coteau du braden délivre
ses premières à rome les bénévoles de
l'association sont optimistes le vin
breton a de l'avenir dans le finistère
les côtes d'armor et le morbihan et en
plus en quantité on parle notamment du
la plantation le vignoble charge aux
vingt-sept mille pieds quand même quoi
donc je pense qu'il ya renouveau quand
même du vin breton c'est à dire que les
conditions climatiques faut que ben a
effectivement bon ben je pense qu'on va
gagner nous au point de vue température
ensoleillement
il ya des dizaines de nouveaux
producteurs qui vont qui plante qui vont
qui ont planté qui vont planter dans les
deux ans à venir là encore et je crois
dans trois quatre ans on commencera
trouver du bois breton dans les rayons
les 115 bénévoles du coteau du braden
bichonnent leurs vignes sur 2000 mètres
carrés plus de 900 pieds de vigne ont
produit dans dernier 1200 litres du
doubs breuvage c'est deux fois moins
qu'en 2018 ou le cru futé exceptionnel
il faut dire qu'ils ont acquis en 15 ans
une solide expérience on sert un peu
maintenant de référence pour la région
la plupart des toutes les veilleurs
environs viennent ici s'adressait
nullement de goûter le vin déjà se
rendre compte que c'est très fort c'est
très possible
pour preuve que c'est du sérieux
l'université de rennes 2 vient
d'installer une station météo sur le
coteau quimpérois comme sur 20 autres
vignobles breton donc c'est relié
directement à la reine et ils vont ils
vont faire une étude de climat
température
miniter enfin tout il y aura un suivi
d'avoir quasiment tous les vignobles qui
s'implantent en bretagne avec toutes ces
données l'idée bel et bien d'améliorer
la qualité du vin qui accompagnera à
merveille une autre spécialité bretonne
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
de gravité des territoires sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
ainsi que sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve très vite faut revoir à
tous
[Musique]